We now continue with the
development of continuous
analogs of everything we know
for the discrete case.
We have already seen a few
versions of the total
probability theorem, one version
for events and one
version for PMFs.
Let us now develop a
continuous analog.
Suppose, as always, that we have
a partition of the sample
space into a number of
disjoint scenarios.
Three scenarios in
this picture.
More generally, n scenarios
in these formulas.
Let X be a continuous random
variable and let us take B to
be the event that the random
variable takes a value less
than or equal to
some little x.
By the total probability
theorem, this is the
probability of the first
scenario times the conditional
probability of this event given
that the first scenario
has materialized, and then we
have similar terms for the
other scenarios.
Let us now turn this equation
into CDF notation.
The left-hand side is what we
have defined as the CDF of the
random variable x.
On the right-hand side, what we
have is the probability of
the first scenario multiplied,
again, by a CDF of the random
variable X. But it is a CDF that
applies in a conditional
model where event
A1 has occurred.
And so we use this notation to
denote the conditional CDF,
the CDF that applies to the
conditional universe.
And then we have similar terms
for the other scenarios.
Now, we know that the derivative
of a CDF is a PDF.
We also know that any general
fact, such as this one that
applies to unconditional models
will also apply without
change to a conditional model,
because a conditional model is
just like any other ordinary
probability model.
So let us now take derivatives
of both
sides of this equation.
On the left-hand side, we
have the derivative of a
CDF, which is a PDF.
And on the right-hand side, we
have the probability of the
first scenario, and then the
derivative of the conditional
CDF, which has to be the same
as the conditional PDF.
So we use here the fact that
derivatives of CDFs are PDFs,
and then we have similar terms
under the different scenarios.
So we now have a relation
between densities.
To interpret this relation,
we think as follows.
The probability of falling
inside the little interval
around x is determined by the
probability of falling inside
that little interval under
each one of the different
scenarios and where each
scenario is weighted by the
corresponding probability.
Now, we multiply both sides of
this equation by x, and then
integrate over all x's.
We do this on the
left-hand side.
And similarly, on the right-hand
side to obtain a
term of this form.
And we have similar terms
corresponding
to the other scenarios.
What do we have here?
On the left-hand side, we have
the expected value of x.
On the right-hand side, we
have this probability
multiplied by the conditional
expectation of X given that
scenario A1 has occurred.
And so we obtain a version of
the total expectation theorem.
It's exactly the same formula
as we had in the discrete
case, except that now X is a
continuous random variable.
Let us now look at a simple
example that involves a model
with different scenarios.
Bill wakes up in the morning
and wants to go to the
supermarket.
There are two scenarios.
With probability one third,
a first scenario occurs.
And under that scenario, Bill
will go at a time that's
uniformly distributed between
0 and 2 hours from now.
So the conditional PDF of X,
in this case, is uniform on
the interval from 0 to 2.
There's a second scenario that
Bill will take long nap and
will go later in the day.
That scenario has a probability
of 2/3.
And under that case, the
conditional PDF of X is going
to be uniform on the range
between 6 and 8.
By the total probability theorem
for densities, the
density of X, of the
random variable--
the time at which he goes
to the supermarket--
consists of two pieces.
One piece is a uniform
between 0 and 2.
This uniform ordinarily would
have a height or 1/2.
On the other hand, it gets
weighted by the corresponding
probability, which is 1/3.
So we obtain a piece here that
has a height of 1/6.
Under the alternative scenario,
the conditional
density is a uniform on the
interval between 6 and 8.
This uniform has a height of
1/2 again, but it gets
multiplied by a factor of 2/3.
And this results in a height
for this term that we have
here, which is 1/3.
And this is the form of the PDF
of the time at which Bill
will go to the supermarket.
We can now finally use the total
expectation theorem.
The conditional expectation
under the two scenarios can be
found as follows.
Under one scenario, we have
a uniform between 0 and 2.
And so the conditional
expectation is 1, and it gets
weighted by the corresponding
probability, which is 1/3.
Under the second scenario, which
has probability 2/3, the
conditional expectation is the
midpoint of this uniform,
which is 7.
And this gives us the expected
value of the
time at which he goes.
So this is a simple example, but
it illustrates nicely how
we can construct a model
that involves a number
of different scenarios.
And by knowing the probability
distribution under each one of
the scenarios, we can
find the probability
distribution overall.
And we can also find the
expected value for the overall
experiment.